Transcriber: Zeynep Tan
Gözden geçirme: Yiğit Yıldırım
İlk defa kendi başıma yemek sipariş etmeye
cesaret ettiğimde
sadece 14 yaşındaydım.
Ailemle bir restorana gitmiştik
ve gerçekten çok kalabalıktı.
Kalbim çok hızlı atıyordu.
Nefes alamıyordum.
Bayılacak gibi hissediyordum.
Yüzüm kıpkırmızı olmuştu.
Garsonla göz teması kurdum ve “Bir
porsiyon iskender kebap lütfen.” dedim.
Birçok insan için çok sıradan
bir şey olsa bile
bunu yapabileceğimi
asla tahmin etmemiştim.
Beni yıllarca geride tutan bir zincirden
kurtulmak için
bir adım daha yaklaşmıştım.
Bu zincirin adı sosyal anksiyeteydi.
Sosyal anksiyete ne bilmeyenler
için kısa bir tanım yapayım.
Sosyal anksiyete, kişinin sosyal
durumlarda aşırı güvensiz hissetmesi;
başkaları tarafından yargılanacağı, dalga
geçileceği veya reddedileceğini düşünmesi
ve yoğun kaygı yaşaması durumdur.
Peki benim bugün bu sahnede bu kadar
çok insanın içinde ne işim var?
Sosyal anksiyetesi olan birisinin
kabusunu yaşıyor olsa gerek.
Bugün ben size girişimcilik
hikayemi anlatacağım.
Benim sosyal anksiyeteyle olan hikayem
yalnızca 9 yaşında başladı.
O zaman akranlarım tarafından sürekli
zorbalığa uğruyordum
ve evde de hayat bazen zordu.
Bu deneyimlerden sonra sosyal anksiyete
yaşamam gereken bir şeye dönüştü.
Maalesef ki büyüdükçe deneyimlerim
daha da zorlaştı.
Hatta 15 yaşındayken hayatıma son
vermenin çözüm olabileceğini
bile düşündüm.
Neyse ki bunu yapmadım ve yardım
almaya karar verdim.
Yardım aldığımda yalnız olmadığımı, beni
seven ve desteyen birçok insan olduğunu
ve iyileşebilmek için bir umudum
olduğunu gördüm.
Yardım almanın hayatımı ne kadar iyi
etkilediğini gördükten sonra ben de
başka çocuk ve gençlerin alabileceği
yardım eli olmaya karar verdim.
Yaşadığım yıkıcı deneyimleri dünyada
pozitif bir etki yaratabilmek için
kullanma gücü buldum kendimde.
Mart 2020′de COVID19
Türkiye’ye gelmişti.
Ben de bu izolasyon ve belirsizliğin
gençlerin ruh sağlığını olumsuz
bir şekilde etkileyebileceğini
düşündüm ve araştırmaya koyuldum.
UNICEF’e göre karantinada gençlerin
yaklaşık %50′si depresif veya
endişeli hissediyordu.
Bu bulgular beni ne kadar üzse de aynı
zamanda motive etti ve ben de bir
organizasyon kurmaya karar verdim.
Nisan 2020′de Türkiye’nin ilk ve tek
gençler tarafından yürütülen ruh sağlığı
organizasyonu olan
One Smile Effect’i kurdum.
Misyonum çok kolaydı.
COVID19 döneminde gençleri duygusal
olarak desteklemek.
Ve ben de o misyona ulaşabilmek için bir
takım kurmaya karar verdim.
Hatta ilk takım başvurularımızı
daha dün gibi hatırlıyorum.
Sadece 8 başvuru almıştık ve şu an
aldığımız başvuru sayılarına
göre bu çok küçük bir rakam
ama ben çok mutluydum.
Dünyanın birçok ucundan gençlerin
benim projemi desteklemek
istediğine inanamamıştım.
Hatta salona koşup anneme bu haberi
verdiğimi bile hatırlıyorum.
İkimiz de çok sevinçliydik.
Ben o gün kendime bir söz verdim.
Bu coşkuyu liderliğim süresince
sürdürecektim ve hâlâ bu sözü tutuyorum.
Küçük bir takımla başlamış olsak bile
şu ana kadar 20 ülkeden 100′den fazla
gönüllüyle birlikte çalıştık.
Ücretsiz ve erişilebilir ruh sağlığı
kaynakları oluşturduk.
Eğitim ve farkındalık
programları geliştirdik.
Bariyerleri aşıp dünyanın birçok
ülkesinden gençleri birbirine bağladık ve
kurulduğumuz andan itibaren 60 ülkeden
3 binden fazla genci etkilendik.
Benim dünyayı değiştirme hikayem küçük bir
platform olarak başlasa da şu an bu
platform küresel ödüllü bir global
organizasyona dönüştü.
Ben bu serüvenime başladığımda
yalnızca 15 yaşındaydım.
Dediğim gibi herhangi bir girişimcilik
deneyimim yoktu, ilk defa
böyle bir şey yapıyordum.
Bu yüzden çok fazla
çok korkutucuydu.
Özellikle sosyal anksiyetesi olan
ve içe dönük bir insan olarak
bunları başarabileceğim asla
aklıma gelmezdi.
Hepsi imkansız birer hayal olarak
görünüyordu. Ancak bu doğru değildi.
Ben korkularımın üstüne giderek, hatalar
yaparak ve hatta kendimi birçok kez
rezil ederek
hayallerimi gerçekleştirebilmiştim.
Birçok ödülün yanı sıra Yale
Üniversitesi’nin yaz okuluna ve dünyanın
en prestijli araştırma programlarından
biri olan
Pioneer Academics’e
burslu olarak kabul aldım.
Bu başarılarım benim küçük adımlarımın
büyük değişimlere önayak
olabileceğini gösterdi.
Sizler de küçük adımlar atarak
hayallerinizi gerçekleştirebilir,
dünyayı daha iyi bir
yer haline getirebilirsiniz.
Unutmayın, cesaret korkusuz olmak değil;
korkularına rağmen ilerlemek demektir.
Peki siz korkularınıza yenik mi
düşeceksiniz? Yoksa onlara meydan okuyup
hayallerinizi mi gerçekleştireceksiniz?
Karar sizin.
Neyi bekliyorsunuz?